In object orientated analysis we saw that nouns could give us a good lead into
what the classes are going to be. Similarly verbs can be used for
several purposes one of which is to describe what the relationships are between
the classes. In UML there are three kinds of relationships.
There are associations. For example, association between people and
vehicles, people drive vehicles.
There's generalization, that is a car is a kind of vehicle. And
there's dependencies. There might be a dependency between cars and
pollution laws. If a pollution law changes, cars might have to be adapted.
For example, putting on some kind of pollution control device.